WE'RE BEGINNING THIS HOUR WITH
NEW CNN REPORTING THAT TAKES US
BEHIND THE SCENES REVEALING JUST
HOW CLOSE THE SUPREME COURT CAME
TO SAVING ROE V. WADE.
ACCORDING TO MULTIPLE SOURCES
CHIEF JUSTICE JOHN ROBERTS
FOUGHT TO THE BITTER END TRYING
TO CONVINCE HIS FORMER
CONSERVATIVE JUSTICES TO
PRESERVE THE CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHT TO ABORTION.
BUT IT WAS THE UNPRECEDENTED
LEAK OF A DRAFT OPINION
REVERSING ROE THAT MAY HAVE HAVE
DOOMED ROBERTS' EFFORTS.
>> AND THE ABORTION RIGHTS DRAMA
THAT TESTIFIED IN APRIL THAT THE
DRAFT OPINION WOULD SOON BE
PUBLISHED.
TENSIONS OVER THE FATE OF ROE
WERE HEIGHTENED OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LEAK THAT DIMINISHED
WHATEVER CHANCE ROBERTS HAD TO
DISLOCH THE FIVE VOTES TO
OVERTURN THE RULE.
>> JOINING US, JOAN BISCUPIC.
JOAN, TELL US HOW HARD HE WAS
FIGHTING TO BRING SOME FOLKS
OVER TO HIS TIME.
>> GOOD MORNING, BRIANNA AND
JOHN.
EXTREMELY HARD.
HE WAS TRYING WEEK AFTER WEEK
AFTER THE INITIAL VOTE IN
DECEMBER AFTER ORAL ARGUMENTS AT
WHICH FIVE ZBRUSZS FAR ON THE
RIGHT VOTED TO OVERTURN ROE,
ROBERTS WAS ALONE IN THE MIDDLE
WANTING TO UPHOLD THE BAN ON
ABORTIONS BUT NOT GO FARTHER
THAN ROE, BUT OF COURSE, YOU
HAVE THE THREE LIBERALS SAYING
WE DON'T WANT TO DO ANY OF THIS,
WE DON'T WANT TO DISRUPT
ABORTION RIGHTS AT ALL.
ROBERTS KEEPS TRYING.
AND IT'S INTERESTING, BRIANNA,
NOT ONLY DID HIS WORK AFFECT HIS
EFFORTS TOWARDS THE TWO NEWEST
JUSTICES, BRETT KAVANAUGH AND
AMY CONEY BARRETT, BUT IT HAD AN
EFFECT ON THE OTHERS.
THE HARD RIGHT JUSTICES BECAME
CONCERNED THAT HE COULD BE.
AND HE WAS ABLE TO PICK OFF
JUSTICES ON THE FAR CONSERVATIVE
SIDE FOR MORE OF A MODERATE
CONSERVATIVE CENTRIST.
SO THEY BECAME ANXIOUS WHAT HE
WAS UP TO.
AND THE LIBERALS WHO HAD SUCH A
DEFEAT THIS SESSION, STARTING TO
HAVE HOPES THAT MAYBE ROE WOULD
NOT BE OVERTURNED COMPLETELY.
BUT THEN ON MAY 2nd, WHEN THE
DRAFT OF THE OPINION WAS
RELEASED AND EVERYTHING WENT
PUBLIC, IT MADE JOHN ROBERTS'
EFFORTS ALL THE HARDER BECAUSE
HE'S A MAN WHO LIKES TO WORK
PRIVATELY, IN SECRET, OFFERING
SOME CONCESSIONS HIMSELF.
SEEKING CONCESSIONS FOR SOME
SORT OF, AS I SAY,
CROSS-IDEOLOGICAL COMPROMISE.
IT WENT DOWN TO THE WIRE,
ACCORDING TO MY SOURCES, BUT IN
THE END, HE MADE NO HEADWIND.
>> FIRST VOTE, I LEARNED FROM
YOUR MAJORITYING BACK IN
DECEMBER.
EARLIER THAN WE REALIZE.
YOU SAID IT WENT DOWN TO THE
WIRE, THOUGH DID AMY CONEY
BARRETT OR BRETT KAVANAUGH GIVE
ANYONE ANY REASON TO BELIEVE
THEY WERE GOING TO SIDE WITH
ROBERTS ON THIS?
>> THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION,
JOHN.
ESPECIALLY WITH BRETT KAVANAUGH
WHO COUNTS AMBIVALENT AND SENDS
MIXED SIGNALS BUT THEN IN THE
END SIDED WITH THE FAR RIGHT TO
DECIDE HOW MUCH ENCOURAGEMENT HE
MIGHT HAVE GIVEN TO THE CHIEF.
ASSIGNED IT, HIS VOTE WAS SOLID,
BUT HE NEVER SAID THAT HE WASN'T
GOING TO LISTEN TO THE CHIEF.
SO THE CHIEF KEPT TRYING.
THE THING THAT HAPPENED, AS I
SAID, REALLY THWARTED THINGS,
WAS WHEN IT WAS CLEAR TO THE
PUBLIC HOW JUSTICE KAVANAUGH AND
JUSTICE CONEY BARRETT MAY HAVE
VOTED.
IT LOCKED THEM IN AND MADE IT
ALL THE MORE DIFFICULT.
AND, YOU KNOW, I DO THINK THAT
BRETT KAVANAUGH DESPITE WHAT HE
SAID DURING HIS CONFIRMATION
HEARING AND DESPITE THE WAY THAT
HE SORT OF PUBLICLY WRUNG HIS
HANDS OF THIS ISSUE WAS LIKELY
NEVER GOING TO SWITCH.
HE WAS PROBABLY NEVER GOING TO
CHANGE AFTER HE FIRST SAID THAT
HE WANTS TO REVERSE ROE.
HIS SIGNAL FROM THE BENCH DURING
THE ORAL ARGUMENTS, JOHN IN
DECEMBER, BEFORE THEY TOOK THAT
VOTE WAS, YOU KNOW, PRETTY
STRONG.
IT'S JUST THAT HE HAS BEEN IN
PLAY BEFORE, AND THE CHIEF JUST
DID NOT WANT TO GIVE UP.
HE FELT LIKE THIS DECISION WOULD
BE SO WRONG.
THEY DID NOT EVEN TAKE THIS CASE
TO DECIDE ROE V. WADE.
THEY TOOK THE CASE TO DECIDE
WHETHER A BAN ON 15 WEEKS -- A
BAN OR ABORTIONS AT 15 WEEKS'
PREGNANCY WAS CONSTITUTIONAL.
ROE V. WADE AND THE 1992 PLANNED
PARENTHOOD VERSUS CASEY HAD SET
UP A FIREWALL, ESSENTIALLY.
>> YES.
>> OF VIABILITY, THAT STATES
COULD NOT INTERFERE WITH A
WOMAN'S RIGHT TO ABORTION WHERE
A FETUS WOULD BE VIABLE OUTSIDE
THE WOMB AT 22 WEEKS.
>> THEY TOOK AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE.
THAT LEAK, AS YOU SAID,
CEMENTING THINGS IS UNDER
INTERNAL INVESTIGATION AT THE
COURT.
WHAT'S THE LATEST ON THAT
INVESTIGATION?
>> OKAY, SO, YOU KNOW, WE'RE
SEVERAL MONTHS IN AND LAW CLERKS
AND PERMANENT EMPLOYEES HAVE
BEEN ASKED TO TURN OVER
ELECTRONIC DEVICES.
THEY'VE CONTINUED WITH THE
SEARCH.
BUT THERE'S -- NOBODY'S BEEN
CAUGHT.
AND THERE'S JUST A LOT OF
SKEPTICISM INSIDE, THAT DESPITE
HOW AGGRESSIVE THE INVESTIGATION
HAS GONE, THAT THEY'RE NOT CLOSE
TO FINDING OUT WHO IT IS.
YOU KNOW, THAT DRAFT WAS DATED
FEBRUARY 10th.
AND IT BECAME PUBLIC THROUGH
POLITICO, WHEN IT PUBLISHED IT
ON MAY 2nd.
SO, YOU KNOW, IT COULD HAVE
CHANGED HANDS.
IT MIGHT NOT JUST BE UNSIONE SI
PERSON.
YOU DON'T KNOW HOW STRATEGIC IT
WAS THAT SOMEONE DID TRY TO LEAK
IT.
YOU KNOW WHAT, IN THE END, THE
EFFECT IT HAD, IT COULD VERY
MUCH HAVE BEEN A VERY STRATEGIC
LEAK, BRIANNA.
>> JOAN, THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OF COURSE, WE CAN CHECK OUT YOUR
ESSENTIAL REPORTING AT CNN.COM.
GREAT STUFF, JOAN.